salut les mantallot souvent dans les
commentaires je vous lis et puis vous
mettez mais comment tu fais qu'est ce
que tu vois que la personne dit stop etc
malgré toutes les explications c'est
vrai que j'utilise plein de choses
différentes pour essayer de voir quelque
chose sur le visage et dimanche dernier
il ya julien de ruyck est venu à la
maison on a fait une vidéo ensemble sur
un autre sujet sur le développement
personnel j'en ai profité pour le film
et de très très près en lui demandant de
penser à une lettre dans quelques
instants je vais vous mettre la vidéo
pour que vous puissiez essayer de
trouver à quel laiterie de pont ce soit
dans quelques instants d'ailleurs c'est
maintenant donc regarder on n'a rien
prévu mais bien d'accord oui je peux pas
savoir ce que tu décides ok tu penses à
une m ok je peux pas la connaître
ok à partir de maintenant tu regarde
toujours ici et tu penses à ta lettre
tout le temps la seule chose que je te
demande c'est que vraiment quand je vais
dire ta lettre tu christope dans ta tête
réellement stop vraiment comme s'il y
avait une urgence
ok donc tu regardes bien comme si tu me
regarder dans les yeux mais ça c'est mon
ami
donc ta lettre ça peut être a b c d e f
g h i j klm
je m'arrêtais là pour moi je les passe
et c'était juste ou pas sinon je
continuerai à lui si je suis d'accord
donc on refait pareil quand tu entends
ta lettre tu christope dans ta tête
sauf que tu vas pas imaginer un an un
danger en même temps je vais te demandé
d'imaginer un paysage un peu idyllique
donc ce petit peuple ajoute a été en
vacances quelque chose comme ceinture
mais en criant stop quand même ces deux
choses en même temps ça marche c'est
parti a b c d e f g h i hockey
toujours le même exercice d e f g h i ok
on est sûr j'ai ouï sur l'arbitrage et
ses rangs merci c'est tout ce que j'ai
besoin
alors je sais pas si vous aviez trouvé
que c'était la lettre g mais ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que maintenant on
a le support pour détailler et que je
puisse vous expliquer images à l'appui
ce qui s'est passé contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser c'est rarement à
l'évocation de la lettre ou de la pensée
précise de la personne qui se passe
quelque chose
mais juste avant en anticipation puisque
la personne est en attente ça crée un
certain stress personnel et tout le
visage va commencer à communiquer juste
avant et je trouve qu'on le voit très
clairement ici quand je dis f
on a tous les muscles qui se prépare à
avoir une réaction et après j'ai partir
de h tout le visage commence à se
détendre un petit peu puisque le job est
fait c'est passé il se concentre juste a
pu donner des motions au deuxième coup
j'ai rajouté une visualisation exprès
pour vous faire un autre exemple avec
toujours le stop de crier dans sa tête
on voit le même réflexe juste au niveau
de la lettre e r et en plus on voit les
yeux légèrement se contracter alors la
pupille ne bouge pas parce que là il à
la lumière directement dans le visage
donc sonne ça ne change rien mais
néanmoins les paupières se contracte un
petit peu comme s'il y avait plus de
soleil que la normale c'est très léger
repas c'est la vidéo plein de fois pour
le voir et ça c'est un autre indice est
pourquoi je fais faire une troisième
fois c'est pas parce que j'avais pas la
lettre je l'avais depuis le départ la
lettre c'est que vous puissiez voir
trois fois d'affilée qu'on a la même
réaction au même endroit ce n'est pas un
hasard
essayez de le faire sur quelqu'un de
mais prenez un choix plus restreint que
les 26 lettres de l'alphabet pour
commencer vous pouvez par exemple lui
demander de penser à un nombre entre 1
et 10
l'essentiel c'est que la personne joue
le jeu avec vous si elle ne veut pas
jouer le jeu mentalement forcément ça ne
fonctionnera pas aujourd'hui sur
facebook sur la fanpage je vous ai posé
une question pour faire une vidéo
ensemble un trucs participatifs qui va
nous permettre de reparler du my maps
ensemble si vous connaissez pas les
mailles maple jouer un lien dans le
descriptif de la vidéo comme d'habitude
je me plaindre dans le descriptif
l'idée c'est que vous montez postiers
dans les commentaires un magma pas vous
que vous faites sur le sujet que vous
voulez un projet quelque chose à
apprendre ce que vous voulez et après je
vais faire une vidéo avec vos my maps et
on va aussi parler de la manière dont
vous les avez réalisé ce qui pourrait
être amélioré et peut-être ça va servir
aussi à la communauté
suivant le my maps que vous aurez fait
et c'est quoi ton facebook c'est dans le
descriptif et abonnez-vous à sa chaîne
là à lui vous cliquez sur cette petite
tête
j'espère vraiment que cette vidéo vous
aura plus qu elle vous sera utile
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de
partir puisque le mental blog c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao
je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23
septembre à la garenne colombes c'est la
date la plus proche de paris si jamais
vous voulez venir sinon il ya toutes les
dates de tournée sur mon site